Lance Reddick is here you've seen him in
a ton of stuff but he's part of the John
wint trilogy which right now I mean to
me in movies if you're gonna be part of
a trilogy John wick is probably the
coolest thing that's out there right now
welcome Lance Reddick thank you how are
you man I'm good
did you have any idea when you sign on
to do John wick do you have any idea
what it was gonna turn into absolutely
not
right no it was one of those things
where I thought well first of all the
reason I when I first got this script
there were two reasons why I wanted to
do the movie first of all you know that
whole trope of the mild-mannered guy who
gets wronged and then goes on a revenge
spree and then he finds out he's a
baddest cat in the universe yeah has
been done gazillion times oh yeah but
neighbors are always kind of like [ __ ]
up first or people there's something
shitty in the childhood there are a good
childhood yeah yeah but I mean I've
never seen that I've never seen it told
that way right the script was so cool
and you know and there was the whole
environment of the Continental and the
and there was this hotel is fast a hotel
for the elite assassins was just so cool
and the character was a kind of
character that I haven't gotten to play
before I mean usually I play people of
authority who talk a lot so to play the
quintessential servant who was who's
taciturn and stoic was really I just
couldn't wait to do that why do you play
authority figures I mean obviously
you're so good as Daniels on the wire
business because you just have an
authoritative energy no I think was the
I mean well there's uh how it tends to
this business tends to type care I think
in terms of casket doesn't be lazy I
mean let me just give me example so when
I auditioned for the wire I had just
come off do I done i play bubbles in the
corner not bubble I play played um I
can't remember his name now in the court
but I could play a crackhead in the
corner right and then I play it a heroin
addict on Oz so when I auditioned for
the wire starred as a detective right on
us I became a heroine yeah and then
became a heroine yeah that's true this
young but still so when
addition first of all they would even
see me for Dennis and then for about
three times into my third time that was
when David disseminated burns were in
the room and he asked David asked me to
read bubbles on the spot and then I was
second choice for bubbles so and then of
course not gorilla took it so and then I
don't know who's maybe a month later I
got the call to read for Daniel's
because I think they were looking for
big names they couldn't find what they
were looking for and then he passed with
me for Daniel's Wow and man like two
weeks later after I'd forgotten all
about it I got a call saying they'd come
back and do it more often be the role I
need a story like this right you and I
audition for something it's always we
don't ever want to see you again it's
never we'd love to give you this part
because you didn't get that one they
pass on you and that's the end of the
show they pass on me literally for the
future of that director he'll never see
me from a project but that's amazing
tonight between you see a show in its
completion like they made the right move
with you and with bunk and with Andre
royally it all works like I can't
picture any of you guys doing any of
those roles different like as each other
Oh Audrey I mean he define I mean it was
a character that was supposed to die by
the end of the first season and he was
he killed the role so much the key me
and he kept around to the end to the
show was it all Mar supposed to be like
a six episode arc or something no more I
don't know I don't know um interesting
left because I met the guy that he was
based on it's very interesting guy it
wasn't he
I believe he was in one of the episodes
he played one of the prisoner did he
didn't was the episode that I remember
him from is when Omar gets sent to
prison yeah he thinks that he's about to
get killed and he's one of the two guys
who come up to me and they finally finds
out that they're Benson yeah yeah the
real and the real guy who the corner was
based I know he was in a couple episodes
and he passed away the guy with the
whole thing was based on wait well well
I think Gary the lead character from the
corner I don't I think he was actually
Pet passed away by the time we did the
wire who I'm thinking of the guy who is
brother moos owns the guy who he hung
out with I don't remember his real name
Oh what you mean his uh his bodyguard
yeah oh my gosh Ben Oh what Kennedy was
named the son
from the corner I mean the real guy they
add a bend I think of it cuz I met him
in a rep party once I can't think of his
name either be good but he died well
funny thing is like the cat oh you may
or may not know I know it suppose to be
talking about talk about a challenge
great yeah but but I mean the character
that I believe Avon Barksdale is based
on is the one of the biggest drug
dealers in history of Baltimore and a
little Melvin who actually had burns
actually caught him and actually they
became friends he started visiting him
in prison Wow play the preacher plays
yeah he plays the preacher in the show
yeah yeah the little meek guy he's
always coming around the positive
message that was like that was the big
drug dealer
yeah is there any kind of like a
depression or sadness I mean I'm sure
there's sadness but any kind of like
emotionally when a show like the wire
ends and I mean everybody associated
with that show had to know they were
doing a once in a lifetime special thing
when it comes time to move on to the
next thing is there a feeling like how
am I gonna replace something that is
this good no there isn't
well I shouldn't say that as a as a
general statement probably but specific
to the wire no I I speak for myself only
because ours are everybody's
associations of the wire now or because
it's become it's worldwide phenomenon
but when we were on we were like that
black Shawn HBO the nobody was watching
like we almost got canceled I see is
that worth anyone no award it was only
nominated I think for a couple of
writing Awards in season 5 what was
nominated for writing in season 2 and it
lost the house writing in season 5 it
didn't win no but the cast
nope was never nominee for any awards it
was never not many for best series they
won one DGA award the last season how
did it not happen nobody get nominated
for an acting award not even now how
does that is it because they they told
the story in a way that Hollywood wasn't
comfortable I don't understand how that
could happen at the time
you want my I mean yeah my blunt yes
perspective it was just too black there
was just too many there was just too
many three-dimensional black people
black men in particular and too many on
too many levels of power
it was just head spinning I mean just
doesn't like about I just think it was
one of those because because part of it
was soaked was so uh screwed up about it
was that we were on like we were the
lead into The Sopranos so we were on
when the sopranos and 6 in the city and
Six Feet Under and entourage wrong so
all those shows were getting I mean
Award nominations up the wazoo right and
it was the for us it was crickets wow
it's really crazy could the soprano it
was an amazing show but above all the
that that show seems to be the one like
that gets the most respect from other
actors wire is the wire yeah well like
now the wire is like the biggest show
we'll look maybe it works at maybe give
us throne like in the history of HBO but
at the time Sopranos and I'm not you
know I'm not gonna lie I mean in terms
of kind of changing the landscape of
television Sopranos the show that did it
yeah yeah yeah but Sopranos is
incredible but it's almost this thing
where everybody always knew it was
incredible it wasn't there to discover
later where's the wire is this thing
where people were like oh my god this
has just been sitting here well one of
the things that for me that's so amazing
about the wire is that I feel like part
of the part of the the mentality that
kept it not not being talked about in
Hollywood you know there's this there
was there's there's for so long there's
been this notion that like for example
black films don't self at the mainstream
or dinner you know people only want to
see themselves yeah but the thing that's
so cool about the wire is that how it
got big was by word of mouth and it was
huge in it became huge in Europe
particularly the UK and believe it or
not in Sweden and Scandinavia Wow way
before it was in the United States Wow
yeah I mean just because good television
good stories yep go beyond any sort of
like yeah experiences it's just
everybody loves good stories yeah I
think it's a disservice to I think
people are a lot more
but a lot more intelligent than a lot a
lot of times the powers that be given
credit for honestly I hate to do a
cornea radial you know bring it back to
what we're here to talk about but for
John wick the first time I saw John wick
I'm going you know it's just another
cheesy action movie I guess I just put
it on and see what this thing is and
then it was this story that I got locked
into and I'm going oh my god this is
like on my list of movies now this is
amazing I mean it's the characters I
mean we talked about the action too
because that's of course I mean how it
changed American action yes Wow is its
own thing but just in terms of a an
action film that has characters that are
that interest that that many cool
interesting characters I mean it almost
feels like it's weird because it almost
feels like a character-driven piece not
an action driven piece but yeah
characters are so deep and rich
what's Keanu like what's counter Rives
like because he's he's one of the few
who I feel like had the opportunity to
be rep it George Clooney type and just
decided to kind of not be his public you
know what I mean kind of decided to do
his own thing when he said you turned
you mean in terms of kind of being a
public persona
yeah he said it'd not be a public figure
and just kind of focus more on the work
that he wanted to do that's think that's
from watching from afar that's what I
feel like from watching up close that's
against his impression yeah I mean he's
a very my experience of kanima is that
he's a very private guy he's really um
one of the things I didn't because I
hadn't didn't really know much about his
life or personality but because what you
just said I didn't know what to expect
so uh one of the things that really kind
of threw me besides just how intense he
is when he's working
yeah was how thoughtful and sensitive he
is he's uh and he's very it sounds like
a cliche to say he's very kind and I'm
not even people that I think are like a
good guy yeah I'm not used to that right
Yeah right but by the same token he's
very
he's very guarded when it comes to
personal space I mean you don't get in
easily
right now the type of guy you become
best buddies with a relationship if he
wants to but I mean cuz that's that's
flipside you know he's not a star for
nothing I mean he's there's that kind of
the shy sensitive artist who's also like
an aggressively assertive macho guy
right did you guys stay friend I'm not
be friends with you than him I'm kind of
shy and introverted too so and so when
we're together it's 20 in McShane is an
extreme extrovert plus Keanu is
believing right he's a theater geek so
he and he and really good friends could
sleep like he knows like every piece of
theater Ian's gonna like his career
that's amazing and so you know with
three of these to be talking and Ian
walk walk away and there's big crickets
house well I remember at one point uh
there was this long silence and he he
just decided to ask me something about
myself that I don't like how do you even
know that yeah he's gonna make
conversation scene researched he done is
he had done his homework yeah so it's a
personalities thing but I mean that for
me personally I mean I love them it's
interesting that you say that you're an
introvert because I didn't realize that
and that's again only because I look at
from afar we're a fan of a lot of your
work so we were talking about the Y or
Oz you know John wink and everything but
one of to me your best works on
television was your appearance on the
Eric Andre show you know I've been a big
fan of the Eric Andre show I watched
every episode I love the show and so and
we were we watched it earlier on the
radio show and kind of familiarized the
audience with it a little bit but you're
the moment that you had I thought was
just one of these moments that a few
other celebrities have had where you get
pissed and walked off the show I
believed it when you said you need a new
desk you slammed your fist into it
the questions were stupid and you left
when you walked out a few minutes later
dressed as the amalgamation of levar
burton for all the chains on
think I want to end LaBarbera and don't
forget this doctor communicate yes I'm a
bare chest of your of your 0% body fat
doors oh those days are gone
chanting I want to be levar burton how
did this come about whose idea was it
was there any hesitation so this is all
ex idea so first of all you know when
balls by the way to pitch that to you
you know here's what we're thinking bare
chest did you put the communicator on
you've got chains on you start demanding
your iconic slave roll balls is his
middle name first of all you know when I
when I got the offer to do the show I'd
never heard of it so I went online to
look at it and I was like I don't get
this and then I spoke to my my agent and
we're of the same generation and she was
like I don't get it either you should
speak to you know so she sent me to
another agent who's like 30 years young
so I said what do you think he goes oh
he's genius you got to do it okay
so Eric and I got on the phone we talked
about some ideas and then what you had
to feel respected by by the way because
Eric for the most part is like not
taking his guests all that seriously or
being respectful enough to work out with
them is more into embarrassing oh it
gets better
okay sorry so we were so this is maybe
three three weeks before all right
get there that day and all that stuff's
goes out the window so then he decides
oh let's try this so that's literally
like in the dressing room like a like I
don't know 15 20 minutes before I'm
supposed to go out there
he's mr. LeVar Burton stuff he said kind
of say this stuff but you can ad-lib too
so and and the moment I mean there was
some crazy stuff that didn't even get on
like for example there at one point he
had done an exercise video on a
television screen playing and he wanted
me to be sitting in the chair kind of in
the chair kind of trying to do the
exercises with the video and the getting
angry thing he said on the next take
just just get pissed off and walk away
and the I mean to slam the desk there
was just spontaneous right there yeah
there's a great moment cuz you really
looked angry was there any hesitation
- doing the whole levar burton thing or
were you going when he's pitched it are
you going while that young agent said
this was genius so I guess that's genius
- I'm gonna do this I mean I am a bit of
a clown so I love that kind of stuff I
mean I'm
my background is traditional theatre not
sketch comedy so I'm always a little
nervous about being asked spontaneously
to improvise but generally if I just
kind of just say can you say swear words
yes you can okay great
so if I if I just pardon me just says
[ __ ] it and just kind of jump off I'm
fine right and that's the way this
happened and so we're all the cursing
and then and the horrible language was
that him are you all at the end when I
said [ __ ] I don't don't
rainbow read me he know you the thing is
you're you're a big Star Trek fan you're
an actor I guess because the Shatner
kind of made you wanna be an actor well
I wouldn't put it quite it's a little
more noise than that not a lot but I
mean because uh I I was just enamored
with it you know what especially when I
grew up on being like it was it was
James Bond and it was Captain Kirk you
know like those the white guys I want to
be when I was eight and it was a weird
thing I mean I know I've told this
appeal I kept till the story recently
but I remember when I was um I think was
in junior I was in a high school and it
was a Saturday afternoon and like it was
rainy or something I was just hanging
around the house and I was in my
father's Dan and I just happen to be
browsing over some books and I saw this
old old volume of Shakespeare plays that
he had from when he was in college and I
just opened it up to Jewish season I
opened up randomly this the the big
speech that Brutus gives the crowd
before Mark Antony comes with the
friends Romans the country and it sways
the crowd and I I started I learned that
speech but I imagined how Captain Kirk
would do it because that read that
William Shatner was a Shakespearean
actor uh-huh but he did it is Captain
Kirk well my version of Captain Kirk is
before I you know he kind of became a
parody of himself by the third season
but Shakespeare I'm pretty good done it
oh you know I haven't done it in like oh
man it's been 20 years since I did but
you've done a live Shh I just I'm
fascinated I can stamp there and
memorize Shakespeare and understand what
it means ironically last you do play I
did was Doogie season who's played Mike
Anthony at the Guthrie yes are you
confident as an actor that you could
take on pretty much any type of role uh
I don't know any type of role but uh I'm
confident my range is pretty big when
you go okay so like for instance when
you are and often when I get something
that I haven't done before I'm like oh
[ __ ] I'm gonna do and then I figure it
out right but that's what that's what I
was gonna ask like when you have to be a
heroin addict in jail do you
oh but also at that time in my career it
was like that's the kind of [ __ ] I was
looking for right yeah yeah would set
but do you go and like do you talk to
other hair and buy a heroin addict well
that was one because they didn't have to
shoot up I only had to snorted right um
I not me not me personally but I had
seen people snort [ __ ] before
friends at parties that would have been
a bad influence that you happen to make
I didn't do anything
yeah horrible like that so you learn
kind of from watching them observing
that yeah I mean and there's been enough
I mean not that you should be doing your
research for movies but I mean there's
been enough kind of people snortin it's
in the culture what do you start on
onset like what do you what do they what
movie it where it was lect electives I
think how does it feel it burn my nose
it does yeah yeah so that sort of like
reaction there is yeah okay how do you
avoid when you're doing something I
haven't I playing or a cop playing this
stereotype of that of that thing like
the stereotypical cop or the
stereotypical heroin addict yeah you
know find the person in that we don't
try to put because I mean first of all I
wasn't playing every one of it I was
playing a cop who's in a situation he
was trying to keep his cover
so the first time I snorted it was for
real was because I at a BC made me off
the floor right so um and you never I
mean you're never playing a cop you're
playing a person who has that job right
do you not I mean
yeah like for example when I you know
when I was doing research for the wire
one of the great things they did for us
was they had us do ride around with
people that were kind of the same rank
that we were and so I met I met a
Baltimore lieutenant
he was a actually he was in graduate
school at Johns Hopkins at the time and
he was he was looking to move up in rank
and he told me the two things he told me
that really struck me one was he said
you always want to try to lead from the
front as much as possible so whenever I
can I try to go on raids with my guys
and he said there's you try to treat
your in some ways you try to treat your
the people under you like your children
and not now that statement not to infant
out infantilized them I hope I'm saying
oh yeah but rather you care about them
that way you know maybe you're
shepherding them and so that was the
attitude I took and the other thing he
told story he told me which really
fascinated me and told me a lot about
kind of the mentality of being hardcore
cop was about an arrest he had to make
up a dirty cop in his house so they
there was this dirty cop and they found
out about him and so they went to arrest
him and he was the first one in the door
and he went in the guy's bedroom and
when he came in the guy reached for his
dresser to reach for his gun yeah of
course and I think he said he said to
the guy who goes please do it because I
would love nothing more than to blow you
away and they looked at me said I
[ __ ] hate dirty cops
and I realized Wow
cops criminal like in turn
like in order to it's all the street
right in terms of kind of kind of the
visceral experience it's all the street
the only thing that's different is the
values right yeah the code of ethics
yeah yeah yeah yeah what is the vibe
like on the set of a show like Oz
because I mean what I and so I wanted
any romances develop mean it's the
moment in my experience it's the most
testosterone-filled set I've ever been
on
yeah like I give you two exams well one
is I would see guys and not infrequently
doing grappling drills in between takes
Wow one guy who's become quite
successful so I'm not name names but he
was telling star once well you know it
was like it was longer they were in
between setups he was telling story was
about about this chick he's [ __ ]
right
so he's um he said you know what going
ahead we're going at it and she says he
said she said yes he goes but my my name
is not Mark and she says oh my god did I
ruin it for you and he said yeah I was
wondering that because one of the things
that made the show the show was that
just when you thought there couldn't be
more bad news there was more bad news
it's like no matter what characters my
personal experience as well no happy
endings no nothing that the only way you
could possibly be satisfied watching
that show is if you wanted bad things to
happen to people because everybody it's
funny got it
it's funny you say that yeah because
when I when I died yeah I found out by
reading in the script which is not the
only time that's happened to me I in
advance know so I was I was mortified
and you know being especially at the
time being caught is intense counted
character yeah I want to be branded when
every role had to do that
well yeah yeah so uh so anyway so um so
I'm thinking
man did I [ __ ] up so I went to Tom
Fontana mm-hmm you know I said you know
I knocked on his door said can I talk to
you said you see yes it um massage you
Kimmy I mean have you been unhappy with
my work he said oh no no no no no you've
been great it's just that the way your
story line was going it was gonna look
like you're gonna happy I have a happy
ending
and we can't have that amount because
that really is I mean I you goat
season-by-season and it's like you get
to a place you know I can't I can't fall
in love like you start to feel like Oh
season 2 version of feature is my
favorite thing and he finally gets
aggressive and he finally it's just
gonna end badly don't get attached
I love we're gonna do we have to wrap
her I love when they do it I love when
they didn't David Simon said we're gonna
break your heart and then he say that
about season 5 oh I don't remember I
thought he said that about see there's
so many cool herbal we're gonna break
your I love when a show does that when
you think it's gonna be happy and they
just cut your throat that's just season
5 that was a ballsy direction to go for
yeah yeah it was one more Jim and Sam
catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the Sirius XM Adam